وقال جميل الخطيب محامي الاسير الشهيد خضر
عدنان عن موكله او ان موكله الصرع على
استمرار اضرابه عن الطعام حتى نيل حريته
او الشهاده اضاف الخطيب ان خضر عدنان
استشهد نتيجه اهمال السجانين لوضعه الصحي
لافتا الا ان محكمه الاحتلال رفضت الطلبه
الافراج عنه بكفاله
الشيخ خضر عدنان كان في مستشفى الرملي في
عياده مستشفى الرملي وهي عياده غير مؤهله
للمتابعه حاله مثل حاله الشيق قدر عدنان
بعد اضراب استمر لمده 87 يوم طبعا الاهمال
مقصود نحن توسلنا من خلال مراسلات من خلال
طلبات من قبل المحكمه العسكريه بنقل الشيخ
خضر لمستشفى مدني الذي هو في اعلى جاهليه
لمتابعه مثل حالته الشيخ خضر في فتره من
الفترات ونحن شعرنا ان هناك سوء في حالته
الطبيه
تطرقنا الى هذا الموضوع في الجلسه الاخيره
وطلبنا نقله وقلنا وحضرنا ان هذه الحاله
لم تدوم بعدم جاهزيه المستشفى ولكن
اداره السجون رفضت